では礼拝、三帰依、五戒文から
始めていきます
司会の方）合掌してください
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sammā Sambuddhassa.（３回）
阿羅漢であり、正自覚者であり、福運に満ちた世尊に、私は敬礼したてまつる
Buddhaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
私は仏陀に帰依いたします（復誦）
Dhammaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
私は法（真理）に帰依いたしま
（復誦）
Sanghaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
私は僧（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします（復誦）
Dutiyam pi Buddhaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
再び私は仏陀に帰依いたします（復誦）
Dutiyam pi Dhammaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
再び私は法（真理）に帰依いたします
(復誦）
Dutiyam pi Sanghaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
再び私は僧（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします（復誦）
Tatiyam pi Buddhaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
三たび私は仏陀に帰依いたします
（復誦）
Tatiyam pi Dhammaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
三たび私は法（真理）に帰依いたします（復誦）
Tatiyam pi Sanghaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
三たび私は僧（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします（復誦）
Pāṇātipātā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「生き物を殺さない」という戒めを受けて守ります（復誦）
Adinnādānā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「与えられていないものを取らない」という戒めを受けて守ります（復誦）
Kāmesu micchācārā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「淫らな行為をしない」という戒めを受けて守ります（復誦）
Musāvādā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「いつわりをかたらない」という戒めを受けて守ります（復誦）
Surāmeraya Majjapamādaṭṭhānā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「放逸の原因となり、（人を）酔わせる酒類、麻薬などを使用しない」という戒めを受けて守ります（復誦）
では慈悲の瞑想です
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように（３回）
私は幸せがありますようにと
繰り返し念じます
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
私の親しい生命の悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の親しい生命の願いごとが
叶えられますように
私の親しい生命に悟りの光が
現れますように
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
（３回）
親しい生命が幸せでありますように
と念じます
生きとし生けるものが
幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものに
悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが
幸せでありますように（３回）
生きとし生けるものが幸せで
ありますようにと繰り返し念じます
生きとし生けるものが
幸せでありますように
はいありがとうございます
ではよろしくお願いします
今日の新春月例講演会になります
会場費のお布施者がいらっしゃいまして
三澤恵理子様、竹澤彰様、田村富士江様
井手伸子様でございます
四人様ですね
その方々と親戚の方々
ご家族の方々皆様に
それからご先祖の方々にも
仏法僧のご加護がありますように
心が清らかになりますように
解脱に達する事ができますようにと誓願いたします。ありがとうございます
今日はお布施のテーマなんですけど
時々
ホームページで出しているその言葉通りではなくて
時々私は言葉を変えたりはしますけど
これはこの
スライドを作る場合のいろいろ
文章の決まりもありますからねそれに合わせて
『心のプログラムを書き換える
「与える」生き方』ということで
Redesigning the flow of consciousness
英語で書いているものは上に書いてあるものの 英訳だけです
ですからそれは説明する必要は
無いんです
お布施と言ったらなんか
説法を受ける時間よりも沢山の時間
聞いているでしょうね
皆様方遠い昔から私の
初期仏教の話も聞いてますけど
その話を聴いている方々も
聴いていない方々も
宗教を持っている方々も
持っていない方々も
誰だってこのお布施という
言葉だけはよく知っているんですね
私は日本でもお布施に関わり
いろんな問題が起きてきたんですね
1回2回だけじゃない
ずっと
私が日本にも相当
年取って死ぬところまで
日本に住んでいたんですからね
来た時、学生の時からもやっぱり
そういうケースを
見て見て
なかなか治らないんですね
トラブルを作ってしまいますね
まぁその理由は
人間がアホということではなくて
これ時代変わっちゃうんですね
ある世代の人々は騙されて
やられてしまって
被害を受けて大騒ぎしても
その人々の次の世代は
またやってしまいますね
同じこと
ですからまあそういうことに
なっています。だからこの
初期仏教で布施の
布施のパーリ語は今日使ってないんです
今日は
全く新しいアプローチで
話したいと思っているんです
ですから経典
結構ありますねダーナについて
布施は仏教用語でダーナというんです
ダーナはギフトということで
ドネーションという意味なんですね
経典にあるのはほとんどこの
お布施するのは在家の方々ですから
在家の方々に理解できる範囲で
語られているんですね
ですからダーナのこのちょっと
超越した、認識次元を超えた
法則を教えてないんです
悪いんだから一つ偈を今思い出して
言います
Dānaṃ khalu sabbavena -
sagga manusa bhogadaṃ
布施とは本来ナチュラル
天界、人間界の
幸福をもたらすんだと
それはとてもナチュラル
当たり前の事ということで
Pariṇāma vasen’eva -
hoti mokkhupanissayaṃ
pariṇāmaというのは進化させる
という意味なんですね
一応制御する、進化させるならば
解脱に達することもできますよと
pariṇāma
これ、回転させる進化させる
お布施を
解脱に達する、そのセクションの
説明はないんです
注釈書ではこのお布施の功徳によって
解脱に達する事ができますようにと
誓願すれば涅槃にも達しますよ
という風な
えらい簡単なところで
終わっているんです
そこでテーラワーダ仏教の世界では
誰にも聞くチャンスがない
ポイントを今日紹介します
難しく
なったら
寝るしかないんです
しかし私にとってはもう
今日初めて簡単なテーマになったんです
提案を皆様から頂いてやる
リストがありまして
私はもう本当に怠け者で
いろいろと考える面倒くさいんだから
一番簡単なテーマにしましょうよと
したんですけど
本当の本当に今までたくさん
喋ってきたんですけど
私にしてみれば一番簡単な
テーマでありまして
それでもチャプターを二つ
忘れちゃったんです
それから最終的なこのまとめの
チャプターも書き忘れちゃったか
ではなくて忘れたんです
書き忘れたではなくて
書いて終わってから、あっと
思い出したんですけど後の祭り
まず我々は、心は
本来、本性として
本能としてどんな働き方を
しているのかと
心は引き寄せるエネルギーが基本です
心はずっとこうやって
外からものを引き寄せる引き寄せる
ということで働くんです
心っていうのは皆様が理解している
心というよりは私は英語で
consciousnessという単語を使いますけど
マインドではなくて
物質は存在するかしないかという問題も
ありまして
quantum（量子）世界では
物質、素粒子は
心次第であったりなかったりという
曖昧、中途半端だと
我々知っている
物質世界は
consciousness 決めればあるんだと
心というのは物質と
ちがったエネルギーで
主人のエネルギーなんです
宇宙のエネルギーで
実際にあるのは心のエネルギーなんです
心のエネルギーが
quantum(量子）的に物質世界を作る
宇宙を作るんです
ということは私の心で宇宙を作れるかと言ったらこれは無理ですね
太陽を作れるかというと
それは無理ですけど
無理ということは今の能力では
無理というだけで
心を拡大すればどうってことは
ないと思いとますけど
だからこの心
consciousnessとちがって
consciousnessという 全体的に働く
という事を理解した方がいいんです
一緒になって働く瞬間だけで
それから心はもう
個としてindividualとして別れて別れて
いっちゃいます
今私たちには
壮大な地球、宇宙があって
莫大に大きい地球があって
その中で蟻一匹ぐらいの大きさの
自分がいるというね
という認識なんです。それは今自分が
持っている心のエネルギーなんです
すごく小さくなっているんです
そこでその心が
例えばこういう風に想像しましょう
consciousnessだけあった
物質世界はなかったと
これはいろいろ仮定、仮説的に
考えなければ
理解できないんです。それで心がある
聖書では初めはなんだらかんだらとか、
あんな感じで
心がこの引き寄せるエネルギー
働いているんです
引き寄せるという、自分自身で
自分の中に引き寄せる
ということになってしまうんです
だから小さくなっちゃうんですよ
小さくなっても
無制限に拡大して働く心だから
割れるんですねバラバラ...
壊れるんです
ビー玉でも、ビー玉の中に力入れてしまうと
壊れるんです。さらに力を入れると
粉々になるんです
そこで、心が物質が
あると
認識してあると思ったらある
心次第で物質が現れてきて
あっ、これは自分の方に
引き寄せよう引き寄せよう
心が物質があると決めたのは自分に
必要だからでしょう？
例えば皆様でも妄想する時は
金があればいいとか
いいゴージャスな家があれば
いいやとか
あればいいと思うのは
自分が欲しいものなんですね
日本中至る所で熊がいた方がいい
とは思わないね
東京23区で至るところで
熊が隠れている、それは思わない
だから心が思うのは
自分が欲しいという
ものなんです
論理的にそうなんですけど現実的に
ちょっといろんなトラブルが
起こるんです
「取る、掴む」働きだと
簡単に理解しましょう。
だからもう宇宙論もOKです
終わりです。自分の心が根本的に
取る取る掴む掴む
というエネルギーで働いているんです
それは皆様に経験があると思います
ちょっと客観的に
自分を観察して下さい
ずっと生きてきて
裏にあるエネルギーは何である
何か取りたいんです
何か得たいんです
そこで２種類あるんですよ
物を得たい
そこは書いてありますから
そのために、こころに
ネガティブな力があるのです
ところがネガティブ、ポジティブというのは
俗世間的な単語ではなくて
電子的な単語だと思って下さい
だからこのネガティブ
だったらそちらに何とかして
引き寄せなくてはいけないんです
一応それはあまり日本語では
言えないんですから
英語のフレーズも書いておきました
無視してください
足らない、足りてない、何かが必要
取りたい、獲得したい、という生き方が現れます
どんな生命を見ても
この衝動がベーシック
基礎なんです
それで、全ての生命の生き方の方向性が定められます
どんな生命であろうが
どんな方向へ生きているのかというと
取りたい取りたい
面白いことはこの
ネガティブエネルギーだから
取ってからポジティブに
なることもないし
ゼロになることもないんです
取っても取ってもまだ足らないんです
その理由はいろいろあります
はい次に行きます
私は何とかまあ
宇宙の話
妄想の世界に入りましたから
それでいろいろ
単語を考えたんですね
Microcosmic black hole
科学的にそんな事あるかどうか
どうでもいいんです、私には
私は科学者が使っている単語をただ
自分の自由で使っているんです
ブラックホールということは皆様は
ある程度で聞いているし
ブラックホールの状況はもう最近色々今
研究もされているし
皆様が知っているブラックホールは
Microcosmicではないんですね
Macrocosmic black holeなんです
例えば我々は今銀河系の
ほんのちっちゃな
本当に惨めな
太陽で、もっと本当に
すごいでっかい太陽たちがいるのに
そこで地球という惑星の中で
生活しているんです
しかし何で銀河系がそんな形を
取っているかというと
おそらくブラックホールの
1つか2つあるみたいなんです
そこで引き寄せるんだから
こんなこのねじ曲がった
形になってしまって
銀河系を食べられているんです
ブラックホールに
私たちの太陽系も
まあ
一回転するためにどれくらい
時間がかかるかわからないけど
相当時間がかかるんですけど
何かどこか
回転しているんです
まだ
一周は終わってないんです
現れて、もうずっと
ブラックホールを中心に回転しているが
まだ一周はいっていない
その間で人間が現れて
いろいろなものになって、もう
地球が壊れる可能性もありますけど
１回転する前に
それぐらい時間がかかります
それぐらい宇宙はスペシャル的に
すごい
想像を絶するものなんですね
認識はミクロの
ブラックホールのような働きです
ブラックホール知っているでしょう？
何でも自分の方に引き寄せる
引き寄せてああ十分、ないでしょう？
太陽たちを引き寄せて...ポイっ
太陽はそれで潰れてしまって
存在しなくなってしまうんです
太陽の重さはもう
重力何でも
関係ないもう、消えてしまう
消えて無になってしまうんです
そうするブラックホールは
もっと足らないと言って
銀河系を丸ごと食べているんですから
今も食べられているんです
敵がいるんです
そこで、私たち一人一人も
ブラックホールだったらどう？
それはMicrocosmic black holeですね
ミクロのブラックホール
だからいろんなものを自分の方向に
取り寄せるでしょう？
取り寄せたものは
全部壊してるでしょう？
我々も自然破壊や
あれやこれやとか言っているのは
今、レジ袋にもお金を
払わなくてはいけないし
それはどういう事かというと
あちらこちらたくさん
作って作って、もう出したい放題タダで無料で出していたんですから
プラスチックごみが増えてしまって
自然破壊
だから人間が取りたいという
気持ちを持って
そういうプラスチック製品を作ることを
発見してしまって
資源は無限にあるわけではないんです
石油の副産物で作っているでしょう
でもそれによって
地球が破壊する
人間が農業して食べているでしょう？
どれぐらい自然の
環境が破壊するのかと
木を全部伐採して
平らにして
自分が食べるものは
cultivate（耕す）する
それで
肥料やら、農薬やら
セスナ機で
出すんですね
どれぐらい破壊かとわかるでしょう？
だから一人一人間は
ミクロのブラックホールなんです
自分一人が今まで生きてきて
どれぐらいの物を
二度と現れないように壊したのかと
わからないぐらいたくさんでしょう？
はい、それは物質があるということで
考えるとそんな話
物質がないと言ってしまうと
話がまた変わってしまうんです
引き寄せる引き寄せるこれで
心が
すごく硬く頑丈になってしまうんです
硬くなるんですね
柔軟性がないんです
すごい何か、性格悪くなるんです
例えば何か物があるとしましょう
人間二人がいる
一人がそれ欲しくて取ったとしましょう
次の人もそれが欲しいんですね
そうするとそれは
あの人の手から取ろうとする
そうするとその人はそれをあげないと
ギュッと握っている
でもこちらもそれは自分の方に
引っ張る引き寄せる
そうすると
誰があれを取る？
力強い、硬い人が取るんです
引っ張る力
強い人が
取って自分の方に持っていくんです
心の場合でも
我々はたくさんの物欲しいんだけど
その人の引き寄せる
力によって取れる量が
決まってしまいます
こころが硬くなって、成長・進化が
不可能な働きに変わってしまいます
取ることしか考えていない
ブラックホールに進化はないんです
変化はないんです
やがてブラックホールは破壊しますが
今日のテーマに関係ないんだから
そのセクションはもう
言わないことにします
心っていうのは
そんな寿命が長くないんです
瞬間だけです
瞬間で
心が現れて消えてまた
次の心が生まれるんです
そこで心っていうのは
瞬間瞬間変化するんですけど
変化しながら流れなくては
いけないんです
その変化で心に
進化する事ができなくなっているんです
取ることだけですから
考えているのは
人間で言えば
人間は一応一般的に物は取る
それから要らない物は処分する
また新しい物を取り入れる
そこら辺でいくらか
バランスがあるんです
ソファーを買ったとしましょう
家の中これでいっぱいに
なってしまうんです
でも５、６年経つと
こんなのは面倒くさい
もう古いし、もっとデザインのいいのや新しいソファがあるでしょうと
言ってその人は
古いソファを
ゴミに出して粗大ゴミとして出して
新しいソファを買ってしまうんです
そこで
普通ですね、それは
古い車を売って
新しい車を買う
例えばある人があまりにも
執着欲が強くて、頑固で
絶対取ったものは離さない
そうするとその人は
新しいソファを買っても
古いソファーはどうしますかね？
捨てない、それはどこかに無理やり
置いておくんです、家の外でも
ちょっとしたトタン屋根を作って
そちらにでも
入れておく
日本でゴミ屋敷という言葉がありますね
テレビで昔見たんですけど
もう本当に大きい家ですけど
入らないんです
2回も全部ゴミいっぱい、終わったら
2回終わったら1回それから
廊下やらどこでもゴミゴミ
あるおばあちゃんですけど
ちっちゃな所でごみの中でこうやって
生活している
道路を歩いてどこかでごみ袋を
見つけたら、それを取ってくる
取ってきて置いておく
そこでこれは危険だから周りの
クレームがありまして
公で
ゴミ屋敷を処分するとなったら
1週間かかったそうです
トラック、20回30回ぐらい
行ったり来たり行ったり来たり
あの人の心って何なのかね
力ない、見たら取る
それ以上考えることができない
だから取るエネルギー、この引き寄せるエネルギーというのは
ネガティブエネルギーなんです
心は硬くなるんです
しかし心の寿命は瞬間だから
進化しない場合は
起こるのは退化なんです
無常はもうどうしようもないんです
真理は一切現象は無常、これは真理です
ですから
自分の心が進化不可能な
状態になってしまうと
そのまま永久的に永遠不滅で
いるわけではないんです
退化退化するんです
ですからこの引き寄せる
ネガティブエネルギー
どんな心もそれなんです
誰の心もそのエネルギーで
働いているんです
これは心の本来の
状況なんです
どんな生もかなり危険なんですよ
ちょっと滑ったら
どうなるかわからないんです
いくらものを獲得しても
こころには足りた気持ちが起きません
足りたと思ったらもう
取ることをやめてしまうでしょう？
起きません
執着だけは消えません
例えば磁石は
鉄分
鉄のものを引き寄せるでしょう？
ある程度で磁石の大きさ
力に合わせて物を取ってから
磁石の
磁石機能が消えますかね？
消えません
まだ取りたいんです
まだ
鉄が入っているものが近寄ったら
取るんです
ですから心の場合は仏教用語で
執着と言うんですね
これは消えません
いくらあっても消えません
はい次にいきます
覚えて下さいmicrocosmic black hole
という
自分の心はね
施しは損の道だと思う
これ当たり前ですよ
心はmicrocosmic black holeなので
あげたら損をするという話には
皆納得します
あげたら、あなたに
無くなるでしょうと
一万持っている人はまぁ
五千円あげてしまうと
あなた五千円無くなったでしょうと
それは損をしますよと
あげたら損するということは
どんな生命も日本人だけではなくて
生き物は誰だってそう思っているんです
あの
試してみてください
一つ例を出します
例えば日本に結構
猿たちがいるでしょう？
猿園とかいろいろありますから
猿にエサあげたりもしますね
猿にバナナでもちょっとあげて
また取ってみてください
優しい気持ち...バナナ
4本セットだったら猿は
そのまま取ります
これ全部食べられないのですから
ものすごく苦労するんです
また皮を剥くこともできなくて
あれやこれやとハチャメチャ
人間の手が動くんだから
バナナ取って皮剥いて、はいどうぞ
それが終わったら次のものを取って
あげればいいでしょう？
そういう猿とのカラクリの
YouTubeもあります
猿に上げたものをまた
取ってみてください
飼っている、赤ちゃんの時から
飼っている猿でもあげません
噛みつくんです
ビニール袋かビニールのネットに
入っているものも
リンゴとか見せたら
取りますね、あれ
ビニールのネットに入ったままで
食べられないでしょうに
皮剥けないでしょう
歯でやりますから
ちょっと、来る来る...では
ネットだけ外してあげますよと
これは無理です
私達もそういう心を持っていますよ
もらったもの、取ったもの
絶対あげません
そこで 、では人間に戻る
人間の生き方 、文化、文明
あれやこれやと言っているこの生き方
basic philosophy（基本理念）は
何ですかね？取る事です
人間に優れた経済学があるでしょう？
エコノミックシステムがあるでしょう？
このエコノミックシステムは
どうやって動く？
取る取るだけで
それでバランスが崩れるんですけど
この馬鹿たちにそれがわからないんです
どんな経済学的に企画立てても
取ることしか考えていないんです
ハチャメチャ苦労していますよ
地球スケールで
絶対変えられません、それは
人類に平等に豊かになるように
絶対にやりません
経済的に財産を獲得する
それリミットがない
どこまで豊かになれば十分でしょうか？
リミットがない
何かイーロン・マスク、よくネットで
出てくる名前があるんだけど
何者かよく私は分からないんだけど
話すると世界で
一番金持ちの人みたいです
そういう人はもっと金儲かりたい事を
考えているみたいなんです
頑張ってくださいね
一部の人々は権力を欲しがる
財産だけではなくて権力も欲しいと
なぜ権力を欲しがるかというと
権力を取ってしまえば財産は
オートで入ってくるんです
そこでこの権力、権力者になった人が
独裁者になってもまだ足りない
そこで取ることの
最後の結果がわかるでしょう？
世にある独裁者の最後どう？
みんな犬猫みたいに破壊されちゃって
殺されちゃうんです
イラクのフセインさんが
下水のどこかで隠れていて
見つけて殺しちゃったんです
カダフィ、国はリビア
40年間か30年間ぐらいずっと
独裁者でいて
財産は自分と自分の家族だけ
石油もあるんですから
すごい金持ちな国なんです
でもリビアの人々は貧乏
でも自分だけで、これを壊せる
やがて若者たちが
追っかけてきて犬猫みたいな感じで
そのたとえ良くないね
我々はそんなに残酷に
犬猫を殺せませんからね
殺しちゃったんです
独裁者はみんな
そういうことになるんです
独裁というのは権力ですから
これでリミットがどうせ成り立つんです
例えばフセインさんが
すごい独裁的な権力欲が
ものすごいあるんだから
隣の国にも
牙を出そうとしたでしょう？
それでやられちゃったんです
だから権力者も
いくら権力があっても足らない
そこで、一般我々はそんなに大げさな
イーロン・マスクに
なりたいと思っている人もいないし
フセインさんになりたいと
思っている人もいないんですから
我々の場合は健康、寿命
美しさ、体力
知識、能力等々を得たいでしょうね
リミットがある？
ないんです
その中で日本で言います
超能力が欲しくて
普通の能力で、いいえ超能力が欲しいと
みんな壊れちゃいますね
しかしいくらあっても
足りませんね
みな精神的に暗い人々なのです
だから人類も他の生命も
心がネガティブフォースで
働くんですから
物を取りたい
いわゆるブラックホールフォース
働くんだから、みんな暗い
人をちょっと貶して
何か言ったらみんな笑うんだけど
皆様なら美しい笑い方できないんです
笑わないと脳が活性化しないんだから
私も誰かを貶して
何か喋っちゃうとみんな笑っちゃいます
けど本当は私の本心ではないんです
はい次にいきましょうか
「得る」は悩み苦しみの道
もう言う必要はないんですね
心は根本的に得るエネルギーで
取るエネルギーですから
それが悩み苦しみの命を作るんです
だから生きるものは
みんなに
悩み苦しみは運命的にあるんです
ブッダが説かれた真理第一
生きることは苦であると
執着しか
持たない人々
恵みは空から降ってきませんよ
そう思っている人はいますよ
神様にロールスロイスという車下さい
とか言う馬鹿がアメリカにいるんです
一番退化している人間がもしかすると
アメリカ合衆国の人々かも
しれませんけど他の国々はそこまで
アホな事はしませんけどね
神様、子供の病気治して下さい
という程度は頼みますけどね
恵みは空から降ってきません
存在は心だけだったらどこかから
降ってくるんですかね？
執着しか持たない人々と
それでこれはみんな知ってますよ
恵みは降ってこないんだと
だからみんな頑張るんです
幸せになるために
頑張るんです
幸せって誰も分からないよ
幸せって何ですですかと
取りたくて取りたくて
足らなくて足らなくて
苦しんでいるでしょう？
何か入れたら
大丈夫だと思っているんです
入れても消えませんから
足らない気持ちが
でもそれに幸せだと
偉そうに言うんです
だから我々は競争したり
戦ったりする必要が
当然成り立つんです
動物の世界では戦っています
海の中でも
生命は戦っています
海の中で生活している生命にも
敵がいるんです
我々にもいます
猿たちにもいます
そういうわけで人間が
知識も使って
競争社会を作って
威張っているんです
完璧じゃんと
かっこいいだろうと
完璧というマーケット
すごいかっこいいね
競争できるマーケット、市場
それで終わらない
自分が持ったもの奪われ...
だって競争しているんだから
必ず奪われる恐れがありますよ
これはたまらないんですよ
取りたくて取りたくて
ハチャメチャ苦労して取ったのに
人類みんな取りたいと、だから
誰かがこれ取ろうとするんです
だから取ったものは
守らなくてはいけないんです
身を守るということも
出てくるのはその意味なんです
命でも取ってしまうんです
我々は魚の命は
何のことなく取ってしまうでしょう
だからまあ
奪われないように
もう取るだけで大変なのに
奪われないよう守るという仕事も
入ってくるんです
それから世の中で
嘘をついたり
誤魔化したり
騙したり
詐欺とかね
色んなからくりあるでしょう？
例えば私に
朝起きて
神にお祈りしている時
神様の
声が聞こえてきました
汝はみんなに
私のメッセージを語りなさいと
言ってそれが愚か者を
何人か選んでその連中に言って
そいつらそれ宣伝してもう
巨大マンモス宗教を作るんです
統一教会の始めは
そういう風に始めたものなんです
あれって何の事もないんでしょう
騙しでしょう？
取りたい取りたい
権力とたくさんの人に崇めてほしい
競争で負けると落ち込みます
あるいは激怒します
だから人間の中で
貧困に陥ってどうしようもない
国々もありまして
恐ろしく激怒して
殺し合いをやっている国々もあります
これは終わらないんです
今日本でも
物価がぐーっと上がっているのは
ロシアとウクライナの
戦争の結果なんです
だから
殺させて
儲かる人々がいるんです
明らかにロシアといウクライナは
儲かってないんです
こころは
頑固になるので
精神的にも
肉体的にも
病に陥ります
この身体が病に陥る理由が
そちらにあるんです
病に陥らない人間がいないんです
全く病気に
罹らないでいることもできます
ただ物質の
エントロピーはどうにもならないから
老いるんです
老いることは病ではないんです
どんな物質も
エントロピーでどんどんどんどん
能力が減っていくんですからね
それは普通
だから生命に病という
問題があるんです
さらに執着はそのままなので
死後もこのドラマが続きます
死後っていうのは
この物体が壊れただけの話で
心が
宇宙的に
consciousnessといったことを
考えなくてはいけないから
続くんです
だって瞬間で死んだら
瞬間で生まれるんだから
心は
これは法則だから
心にもそれは
どうすることもできないんです
俗世間では仏教で言っている
生まれ変わりの話しは悪い、変だ
非科学的だとか言ってますけど
あっそうですか
それはあまり相手にしないんです
だってこれ理解できる能力
ないでしょう？
このスケール破って
超越した智慧で物事を
認識する能力ないんですから
みんな
個が死んでどこで生まれる
俺に過去があったならば
何で覚えてないのかとか
だからそこを宇宙スケールで
考えなくてはいけないんです
これmicrocosmic ではく
macrocosmic的に
考えなくてはいけないんです
そうすると至って単純
当たり前なんです
そうすると今も
生死を繰り返しているんです
今もやっているのに
はいこれ置きましょう、とにかく
最終的に言えるのは
この取る取る
いかに大変な世界かと
生きることが
苦そのものになっているんです
競争競争、戦い戦い
もう勝ったり負けたり
やっと得たものも
簡単に奪われる
それでも
足らない足らないそれでも命に執着
だから私は
昨日夜思い出した言葉が
microcosmic
black hole
どうにもならない
そこで
一方的に取るだけで
やっちゃうと
取れなくなるんだよと
気づいちゃって怯えちゃって
あれも執着欲なんです
人間が
偉そうに格好つけてネクタイも締めて
バランスという言葉
持ってくるんです
バランス取りましょうと
だから世の中で
charity, donation,
volunteer, social welfare等々
単語があるでしょう?
これは日本訳はできないんだから
charity, donationも
全部布施の世界でしょう ？
volunteerは日本語でも
ボランティアですから
social welfareというのは
恐らく社会福祉活動だと思います
それはどんな人間もOKと認めるんです
やるべきだと認めるんです
人助け、自然を守ることなども認めます
人間って立派ね
立派ではないよ
取るだけでは自己破壊だと
分かっているんです
実行することは善、道徳
神に説かれた愛だと思います
でもみんなやりたくないんだから
やっぱり道徳が、モラルが無いと
くだらない事を言うんです
善を行わないとダメだよと
あなた知っているのですかと
善とは何かと
知らんよ
ただギャーギャー言うだけ
それから
神を信じている方々の方が
ものすごく大きいんですからね
地球人口の
神が言われたんだから
愛を実行しましょうと
決まりは
幸福な人が不幸な人を助けることです
それで何をやっているかというと
幸福だと見栄を張っている人々は
不幸だとレッテルを
貼っている人々を助けるんです
あれって
わがまま好き勝手でやっているんだから
助けられる側にしてみれば
迷惑もいいところなんです
世界的にこのsocial welfare活動を
やっているでしょう？
迷惑もいいところなんです
オーストラリアに行った
人殺し屋の白人たちが
オーストラリアに住んでいた人々は
自分なりの言語があって文化があって
いろんな精神的な世界があって
いろんな考えがあったんです
みんな潰しちゃったんです
名前、アボリジニ
いかに汚い、差別用語かと
アボリジニの辞書の意味
知っているんですかね
abというのは品格のない、卑しい
origineというのは生まれです
オーストラリアは
その人々の国なんです
これを奪っただけではなくて
ネイティブの人々にアボリジニと
名前まで付けちゃったんです
ノースアメリカは
ものすごい哲学があって
文化があって色んな
自然と一体になって生きていた人々
だいたいこの
今インディアンと言いますけど
あれもいい加減な単語でしょう？
Native Americansです
Native Americansは
こんな取ろう、取ろうという
気持ちはなかったんです
調和しよう、調和しよう
山と調和しよう、川と調和しよう
鳥たちと調和しようと
何でNative Americanは何とか鳥の羽で
headdress(頭飾り）とかあるでしょう？
あれ調和する目的なんです
今は絶滅になっているんだから
取ってはいけない事になってますけど
ああいうheaddressで
鳥たちに私もあなたと同じ気持ちだよ
と言って踊るんです
仲の良い友達でしょう？
自分に羽がないんだから
殺して殺して奪って
羽をつけちゃって
踊るんです
あれって原始的ではないんです
アフリカの部族の人々は
牛の仮面を被って角もあって
鹿のあれ、色んなの被って
身体中いろいろ塗って
踊っているでしょう
あれが冗談ではないんです
そういう人々は
みんな仲良し自然と一体だと言って
あれ表現しているんです
牛の仮面を被って
牛の本当の角までつけてもらって
踊るんです
だから牛さんに
仲間だよ、我々は兄弟でしょう
というメッセージなんです
どうですかねこの
現代文明人があるいは
非難侮辱すること
primitive（原始的）という単語を使って
はいそういうことで
恐ろしい
取るだけでは何か
やばいところもありますよと
オーストリアでこのアボリジニの人々
恐ろしい事をやったり
ちょっとちょっと読んでみて
神の名においてよくやりましょうと
女たち、シスターたちが
ああいう子供たちを誘拐するんです
サーッと軍人と一緒に行って
ネイティブの住んでいる所に行って
子供を全部誘拐して
その人々は決して髪の毛は
切らないんです
そうすると
自然との
コンタクトが破れるんだと
だから男も女も
生まれてついてきた髪が
伸びるならばずっと
伸ばしておくんです
男の場合は髭も出ますから
髭はずっと伸びるんです
一本も取らないんです
そういう人々には
何かある能力があったんです
自然界と対話できたんです
他の生命と対話できたんです
自分が離れてないんですから
これが悪魔だと
言って子供たちを誘拐して
無理やり頭剃って
髭を剃らせて...　髭はないんだけど
いろんな施設に入れて
文化からも
切り離してしまって
人殺し文化に染めるんです
あのエピソード、ストーリーを読んだら
あーっと思っちゃったんです
そういう神が愛を欲しているんだと
まぁどうでもいい話で
そこで人間が取るだけでは
社会が成り立たないんですから
道徳というくだらない物を
考えてしまったんです
人助けという、人助けではない
ものを考えてしまったんです
分かりやすい
決まりは幸福な人が
不幸な人を助けることでしょう？
ですから、この道徳を実行するために
不幸な人、苦しんでいる人の
存在が欠かせないんです
いかに恐ろしい道徳かと
missionary（宣教師）の人々行って
日本にも来たんですけど
こんな原住民を助けてあげようとか
どちらか原住民かわからないですけど
日本で鉄砲なかったでしょう
鉄砲を作るんだから文化人ですね
鉄砲って何ですか？
どうしても殺したかったら弓でやればいいでしょう
そうすると五分五分でしょう
弓を持って山に入って
獲物を取るということは
ある程度で、自然界のこれは
公平な戦いなんです
鉄砲を持って行ってしまうと
はい、でそこで
特にmissionaryとか人を助けるシステム
世の中でものすごく拡大していますけど
どこかで苦しんでいる人がいないと
どうするのか
マザーテレサがインドに行って
福祉活動したんですね
だから
ホームレスの人がなければ
善行為ができなくなってしまうんです
インド人があんなことは
あまり気にしないと
道路で外で生活するということは
別に...という感じで
ずっと道路でどこかで外で
オープンスペースで生活していて
おじいちゃんにおばあちゃんに
なってくると
なかなか何もできなくなって
ジーっと待っていると
可哀想だと思ってあちらへ連れて行って
どこかの施設に入れて
ご飯を食べさせて、お粥を食べさせて
神を信仰しなさいと教えて
本当に苦しんでる人を助けたことだから
それを批判しては良くないんだけど
私はもっと深い理論で見ているんです
インドで残酷な目にあっている
人々がいたから
マザーテレサさんにノーベル賞を
取るぐらいの善行為ができたんです
世間が語っている道徳を守るために
どうしても不幸な人が必要です
ということは
不幸なこと、貧乏であること
病に陥って苦しんでいることが
必要なことになるんです
では私が助けてあげるとか
私が治療してあげるとか
病に罹って落ち込んでいる人には
薬を買うお金もない方が
体に合う食べ物も買うお金が
ないほうが最高です、それで
善行為をやっている善人がいて
はい、治療してあげます
はい、食べる物あげます
収得哲学で生きるとき
世は傷だらけになります
だから世はいつでも傷だらけなんです
収得する、哲学ですから
それでwelfare serviceという
クリームを塗って、それでちょっと
クリーム塗っちゃうんです
ボランティアやる、welfareやる
あーよかったなとか
あの日本みたいに自然災害で
人を助けることとこれは違うんです
自然災害で避難、避難ではなくて
被害受ける方々を
助けることは純道徳なんです
自分でやったわけではないんですから
自分の経済活動の結果として
地震が起きて人々は
困っているわけではないんだから
それは違います
私はそれで辛口で言うのは
怪我させて手当てすることだと
地球の人類にハチャメチャこの
収得
力がすごい人々は取る取ると
相手が怪我をするんです
例えば占領して
ある国を奪ってしまうと
その国に住んでいた人々は
ものすごい不幸になるんです
自分の土地が奪われちゃったんです
それから手当をする
だから怪我させてから
優しい心で手当てするんだと
それで我々は
本当に立派な方々ですねと
褒めてあげなくてはいけないんです
これは世の中にあるまぁ
チャリティ世界です
はい
次に行きます
ではブッダの話に入りましょう
ブッダの話は人間に理解できない
今、私は世の中でやってる良いことに
すごい辛口悪口言ったでしょう
何という坊主かと思うでしょう
思ったって別に痛くも痒くもないんです
私に言わないでください
私は答えますから
それは消化できなくなります
ブッダが説かれる布施、dāna
解脱への最初の実践
フリーになることの1st stepなんです
The first step towards freedom
あんなものではないんです
はい、次いきます
布施、まずはあの
microcosmic black hole 観念から
考えましょう
Black holeは周りを破壊し続けるんです
我々は周りをどうしても破壊するんです
布施は内向きに働く心を
外向きになるように変えることです
取る取るではなくて
consciousnessの問題なんです
心の問題なんです
あの
こちらにではなくて
外にray（放射線）を出す
放射を出すんです
ものすごい違うことなんです
苦しんでいる人にご飯、弁当が入る
考えではないんです
これ難しいんです
だって心はいつ現れたかという事は
成り立たないんだから
そこからもうトロトロ執着する
足らない足らないと生きてきたんだから
別に足りているんだよ、ということが
そう簡単ではないんです
では例えとして
ビッグバンの事を考えましょうか
ビッグバンの状況は未だに
まだわかってないんですから
科学的にはね、一応
一部の意見は
取るに足らない
ちっちゃな一点でしたと
宇宙は
これで爆発してしまった
いわゆるエネルギーは外に出たんです
どうですかね、もし
宇宙が現れる前に
ちっちゃな点だけでしたならば
そこ、ビッグバンでエネルギーは
外へ出してしまって
今、想像を絶する
宇宙が現れているでしょう？
それがポジティブでしょう？
損している？
一点でいたエネルギーが
もっと取りたいというと
もっと小さくなるだけでしょう？
巨大無限の宇宙が現れたんです
エネルギーを
捨てたことで
損したわけではなく
計り知り得ない
宇宙が現れたんです
俗世間はあげたら損する、相当
仏教では
あげたら計り知り得ないぐらい
得をするんだと
ビッグバンで考えればわかります
ですから我々のconsciousness
我々の心にこの内向き内向き
足らない足らないことなくて
まぁいいや、もう足りている
外へ出します
ということでかなり
すっごい大物になってしまいます
はい
そこで、よく考えましょう
充実感を感じる
充実を感じる
スケールは
極小であっても
与えることで
心は充実感を感じます
あの足らないと足らないという
悲鳴上げて
悩みが
瞬間でも消えますよ
永遠不滅で苦しんでいる心は
瞬間の安らぎ感じるんです
あげた瞬間で
これには値札はつけられません
それぐらい価値があるんです
解放感を感じるんです
”I`m free”と感じるんです
ほんのちょっと、僅かですけど
皆様も誰かに何か
あげる場合の瞬間で
何かfreeを感じる
自由を感じるんです
内向きの心が瞬間であっても
外向きに変わったんだからね
その瞬間心は
悩み苦しみが
心に悩み苦しみがないんです
あげる瞬間で
悩み苦しみがないんです
その経験を思い出して
繰り返して安らぎ・充実感を
感じることも可能で
面白いことは
一点であった宇宙がビッグバンで
無量広大無辺の宇宙を
作っているような感じですから
ほんの僅かなことをあげたら
私たちにとっては
この間こういう良い事ができましたよと
思い出すたびに
安らぎを感じる
だから皆様もう
執着世界だから
数字で言った方が
わかりやすいでしょう？
あげたのは100円ですけど、それから
10億円ぐらいの
幸福をいただいたと
損したんですかね？
思い出しては安らぎ
だからビッグバンの法則ですよ
働いているのは
ストップしないんです
今も宇宙は拡大しています
今もいろんなところで
太陽が現れたりしているんです
施しで得る喜びは
あげたものよりはるかに
多いんです
あげたら損ではなく
得する道はあげることです
得したければ
あげることです
これって物質的にくだらない
レベル低い事で考えないで下さい
今私はブッダがなかなか
人間に理解できない
これを言ってもと
悩んだ所に入って
説明しているんです
dānaを
皆様自分で仏典を読んで開けてみても
そのセクション説明していないんです
人間の認識範囲はちょっと超えています
このまだまだ完成していない科学世界のアイディアを
例え話として取って取って
私は説明しています
はい、次に行きます
このページ番号が
入るようにするの忘れちゃったんだけど
Automated cycle of suffering
というのは、わかるでしょうね
自動で回転する苦しみ
執着の道は悩み苦しみを
自動回転させるシステムです
誰だって執着で
欲しいという気持ちで
生きているでしょう？
足らないという気持ちで
生きているでしょう？ですから
悩み苦しみは
自動回転しているんです
ずっと
無執着、布施
捨棄（しゃき）と読むですかね？これは
捨棄（しゃき）
この回転に
ブレーキをかけて
逆回転
幸福への回転を
スタートします
布施やらあの
無執着とか
経典によって
使う単語が違います
布施っていうのはこの
俗世間在家に教えた単語で
仏教徒たちには
無執着という単語を使うし
修行する人々には
捨棄という単語を使うんです
同じことですけどね
functionality-wise same thing
機能としては同じ機能です
苦の回転にブレーキをかける
かけて幸福の回転に
逆回転させるんです
施しを
布施の実行を考える
方々は
心に起こる苦の回転と
幸福の回転について
理解した方が良いでしょう
皆様それ覚えてください
命が回転しています
苦しみの回転です
施しということを理解できれば
この苦の回転は
逆に幸福回転になるんです
執着の感情が支配する
black hole的な回転と
感情のエネルギーを
放棄する
white hole 的な回転の違いですね
white holeという概念もあります
宇宙科学世界ではね
まだ私はあまりここら辺は
読んで勉強してないんだから
説明できないんです
要するに貪瞋痴の
感情を
不貪不瞋不痴の感情に
変えるために
布施を実践するんです
人があなた困っているんだから
何かあげよう、ではないんですよ
自分の本心である
本能である貪瞋痴を
不貪不瞋不痴にするんです
だからお釈迦様
単語を選ぶときでも
すごい気をつけています
はい
はい、それからもうほとんど
話終わったということになります
それからいくらか
皆様にわかる世間に
入ります
今までの説法はちょっと
人間には消化しにくいぐらい
高度なものなんです
How much?どれぐらいあげれば
いいっていう話
自分が所有するものをあげるので
量はそれ
自分の所有物によって決めます
だからこれ客観的に
決めることできません
みんな100万ずつあげなさいと
冗談じゃないそんなのは
人は所有しているものを
でどれぐらい上げればいいかと
考えればいいでしょう
それでパーセント付けることは
できますよ
1万持っている人は2%お布施する
1000万持ってる人も2%お布施するとか
数字が変わるんだけど
所有するものをあげるんだから
その場合は同じです、徳が同じです
1万しか持っていない人は
2%お布施しました
1000万持っている人も
俗世間的な執着世界では
桁がちがいますよ
でも
仏教心理学の世界では
功徳は
同じです
計算できないけど
1000万円の2%どれくらいですかね
わからん
計算してみてください
だから決して
金額でお布施は決めることは不可能です
いくらぐらいということは
自分が所有しているもので決めるんです
ですから
仏教的な教えの場合は
他人と比較してはいけません
災害の時は
隣の人は
例えば
ペットボトル
水が入っているね
ミネラルウォーターが
入っているペットボトルを
100個
ボックスを100個、donateした
では俺も100個ぐらいあげなくては
ちょっと面子がって...
そんな事はいいんです、別に
自分に、せいぜい自分の能力で一箱しか
寄付できないんだったら
一箱あげてください
もしかするとパーセントで
自分の方が高いかもよ
100個あげた人よりは
ですから
覚えておいてください
隣の人のお布施を
参考にしないこと
そうするとあれは善行為ではなくて
見栄
であって悪行為になるんです
残念ですけど
ただあげただけでは
お布施になりませんよ
布施することが他の生命の
役に立つことになるべきです
あげたら新興宗教組織でその問題
あげればいい
高い金額をあげればいいやとか
あの連中はあれ
金額を持って何するのかと
苦しんでいる人々を助けているのか
日本社会で何かポジティブ的な
ことやっているのかとか
このチェックないでしょうに
だからああいうのは
布施に入らないんです
競争世界で弱い人の金を奪うでしょ
強い人は
ただそれだけです
起きたのは
経済社会で
弱い人は
負ける貧乏になる
強い人は豊かになる
だから新興宗教組織の場合でも
新興でなくたっても
宗教組織の場合でも
結構これ起きているんです
だから泣くんですこれぐらい財産を
お布施したんだけどと
今は苦しんでいるとか
そうではないと「ゴミ捨て」と
似た行為になってしまうんです
時々すごい財産持っている人は
もう別にどうでもいいんだからと
あげてあげて、したりするんです
その人々はゴミ捨てしているんです
例えば税金たくさん払ってしまうと
ヤバイことになる
だから
税金で免除してもらうと
アメリカでは大体
ドネーションしちゃうと
チャリティしちゃうとその税金
減らしてあげるんですよ
だから政府って面白い組織です
たくさん税金を納めている人のこと
なんか斜めで見ている
あいつはやばいやとか
もっと金あるはずだ
もっと取った方がいいと
敵視するんです
だからそういう
すごい金持ちの方々はかなりの量を
チャリティにドネーションするんです
ボランティア活動、福祉活動
いろんなところに
それは
税金を計算するときは
マイナスにしてくれるんです
私はそれって
ゴミ捨てという感じで
ちょっと悪い言葉を使っています
人を不幸に陥れる施しは
また一つ考えてください
悪行為です
人に自分が施したものでその人が
不幸になるならば
やめてください
だから施しする人に
相手を心配する
義務があるんです
欲しい欲しいと言っただけで
あげるんではないんです
例えば頭すごく良い子がいる
勉強やりたくてたまらない
でも片親で学費が払えない
だから義務教育終わった途端
どこかで仕事に行く、かわいそうですね
すっごい
勉強する能力がある
だったらその子に、では学費全部
大学卒業するまであげるんだから
勉強しなさいよと
それは素晴らしい善行為でしょう
なぜならばその子は
親に負担かけないでしっかり勉強して
バイトもしないで勉強できる
もう一応お金貰っているんだから
抜群に
卒業して
独立して仕事をするか
人々のあっ、こんなことをして
私も人助けをしなくてはいけないと思う良いに人間になる可能性
いくらでもあるでしょう
けっして悪い人間にはなりませんよ
だからああいうのはもう本当に
善行為であって
布施なんです
アル中の人がいて全財産使って
酒飲んで飲んで飲みまくっちゃって
家も担保にしちゃって
そうすると
あなた酒飲まなかったら困りますねと
酒は差しあげる
あれは善行為にならない
その人泣くんです
とにかく
カップ酒というものあるんですね
あれは
二つぐらい1日飲まなきゃ
もう死んだ方がマシだと泣いていると
あぁいいよ、一週間分これで
買ってあげますと
表面的には助けるように見えますけどね
それはその人無理やり
公に頼んで、こいつを捕まえて
どこかあれ、何と言いますかね
センターに入れてくださいと
言った方が善行為です
ですからHow much?というとこは
そういう風に決めるんであって
あげる人が、貰う人が幸せになることもチェックする必要があるんです
ただあげただけで
お布施にならない
例えば日本の方々はね
ユニセフに寄付するし
ユネスコいろいろとそこで
何やってるかわかっているでしょう？
はい
次の問題は誰にあげるのかと
ここで
仏教の話をよく理解してください
どんな人にも制限が利かないほど
欲と執着があります
いくらあっても足らないという
欲があるんです
だから
あげて人を満足させること
ありえないんです
ですから
誰にあげますかということも
すごく考えなくてはいけないんです
あげることで相手を
納得させることは不可能です
納得ではなくて別の単語入れた方がいい
満足させること
納得はできますけどね
お腹が空いている人にはちょっと
ゴージャスな弁当をあげたら
本人は、あぁよかった
しあわせだと思うんだけど
明日も一つ買ってくれないか
と言う可能性あります
その場その場で人の問題を理解して
自分の能力も計算して
施しの行為します
その場その場で人に要求が現れる
困ることが現れる
それに合わせて
助けるんです
自分の施し精神を
悪意で搔き立て
物を貰おうとする働きは詐欺なので
そういうのは世の中よくありますよ
宗教的な気持ちを
みんなもっているんだから
あげなさいあげなさい、これ仏教の
宗教も、宗教になっている仏教も
それを派手に謳っていて
お布施を取ってしまうんです
だから私はこんな難しい分析にしたのは
もう
テーラワーダ世界でも
悪用していますよ
あげればすごい功徳になりますから
お布施dānaをしてくださいと
私は気をつけてくださいと
これは智慧の勝負ですよ
布施主に断る権利がありますよ
自分が新興宗教組織
何か宗教組織に入ってしまって
向こうが
強引にお布施を勧めるならば
ありませんよと、お金ないよと
私は心の安らぎを求めてきたんだよと
自分にかかる費用は
自分で負担しますよと
言いう権利があります
しかしあげる能力があるのに
あげませんよと言ってしまうと
それはケチで
心がブラックホール状態なんですね
そういうことで
無理やり勧める場合は
自分が教えを断る
断ったからと言って
自分の修行に
影響はないんです
自分がブラックホール精神で
断ったわけではないんです
智慧で考えて
断ったんです
なぜならば布施は自分の意思で
フリーダムで
あげなくては布施にならない
くれよと言ったらあげちゃうと
本当にお布施心が生まれますかね？
生まれませんよ
まぁ今思い出した例なんですけど
時々1年1回ぐらい
日本の学校の子供たちでも
募金活動をやるんですね
あれは集まったお金で
良いことに使いますよ
教育費を払えない子供たちに
教育費をあげて
いろんな事に使ってますし
時々ユニセフのためにも
募金活動やったりもするし
かわいい子供たちが
ザーッと道路に並んで
1時間近くしかやりませんけどね
お願いしますお願いします
すごいでっかい声でね
喋っているでしょう
その時は問題ないんです
お願いしますと言っても
箱を持ってね
無視していくチャンス
自由があるんです
あるいは逆に子供たちが一生懸命
良いことに頑張っているんだ
と思って、あるいはこういうユニセフに
このお金が行くんだとわかって
寄付することもできます
それは寄付になります
あのケースでも
下さいと言ってますよ
でもちょっと違いますね
あげる人のフリーダムに
邪魔していないんです
でもある組織に入ってしまうと
誰だって
新しいメンバーになるとこれぐらい
寄付しますよと
葬式でどれぐらいお布施すればいいかと
困っている時は
まぁ相場は
500万ぐらいでしょうねとか、すると
あの布施の功徳が
パッと壊れるんです
悲しいのは本当に例えば
日本の社会しか私は知りませんけど
お布施する気持ちで与えたい
という気持ちの人たくさんいるんだけど
１、悪用される
２、本人も布施の功徳にならないように
周り見て、あちら見て
上見て、下見て
360度回って
金額を決めて差し上げたりする
そこはちょっと
考えた方が良いところなんですね
それでどこまで言うんだっけ
自分自身の清らかな気持ちだけを
使ってみるんです
いつでも自分の心を
清らかにしたいということは
忘れないでください
相手の褒め、賛嘆にも乗らないんです
お布施したらこの物凄く褒めてくれると
あまり聞かない方がいいんです
はい
それから
誰にあげるのかというテーマの続き
善人に施しをする
これブッダの言葉なんです
施しは善人に行うべきという
ブッダの言葉は、これ誤解されています
善人とは
道徳を守る人
欲を戒めている人
要求が極限に少ない人のことなんです
その人が困っていると
パパッとあげた方がいいんです
遠慮しないでね
ですから布施主に
負担はないんです
あげて損する事は
仏教では成り立たないんです
あげる、誰にあげる、どれくらいあげる
自分で決めるんだから
私は倒産してもお布施すると
成り立たないんです
脅しはないんです
脅しが入っちゃうと布施ではないんです
それは俗世間にある奪い合いの
世界です
だから決して仏教のdāna世界では
人は困ること、倒産することは
ありえないように
お釈迦様は気をつけているんです
だから善人にあげなさいと
善人は道徳を守っているんだからね
例えば1万円で自分の問題は解決する
2万円ちょうだいとは言わないんです
どれぐらいと言ったら
まぁ一応一万円ぐらいですが
もし助けてくれるならば
いくらか自分で決めて
100円でも10円でも構いませんよと
いう態度取るんです
今1万円がなくて困っていると
善人が言ったからといって
わかりました一万円上げます
という事ではないんです
善人ならどうしてもあげたければ
まぁ
自分にできる範囲で10円でも
5円でも構いませんよ
という状態なんです
困ることも、倒産するおそれも
成り立たないんです
仏教のdānaでは
しかし
困っている人
苦しんでいる人ならば
誰にでも
あげることは
あげることは善行為です
善人を探して探して
行く必要はないんです
人は善人か悪人か
わからないんですけどね
この人困っているとわかったら
適当に助けるのは
お布施であって
これは善行為になります
必ず善人のみ選びなさい
ではないんです
お釈迦様が極悪人にお布施をしても
徳がありますよと教えているんです
極悪人の場合いくらあげても
あいつらもっと攻めてくるんだからね
昔、私はずっと
大阪勉強会に行って帰る時
夜ですよ
その時あるホームレスの人が
駅に、東京駅の中に
いるんですね
私を見たら「お金ちょうだい」
と言ったんです
私は手で行ったんですから
で
1000円上げたんです
それでその人は
ずっと行く度にまたいる
私はあの人を見たら
あっ、また1000円あげなくてはと
1000円用意してあげる
ちょうだいと
言うか言わない前にあげる
なぜかというと
どうしてもその人は
お金に困っているし
食べるものないでしょうし
ホームレスの方だから
別にどうって、困っている人ですから
本人はご飯食べたいという話で
来るんだからね、こうやって
そうすると1000円では一食は
食べられます
そこで続いて続いて
ある日この人はこうしたんです
その日からその人が頂いた
お布施は0円になりました
恐らく喋ったら、2000円でも
一回2000円あげた可能性もあります
はい、一回ぐらいあげたんです
本人が私たちは日本語わからないと
思っていた可能性もあります
だから本当に2000円
必要だったならば2000円あげますよ
むしろその人と話し合ったところで
2000円ではなくてこれ5000円ないと
間に合わないよとわかったら
私は5000円をあげますよ
相手がこちら外人だから
日本語全くわからないという
固定概念でいるんだから
まぁ仕方がなかったんです
徳がなかったということ
善人ではないね、結局は
恐らく, わからない
人間に限らず、生きものならば
誰にあげることも善行為です
人間ではない、動物にあげる事でも
誰にあげる事も
お布施は善行です
あげるものと、量を自分で管理します
何をあげるのかと量を
私は猫と一緒で人参どうですか？
あげました、と言うだけで
それはお布施の世界ではないんです
猫は人参食べない
で
玉ねぎ食べたら猫には毒なんです
「あなた玉ねぎ食べないの？」
持ってきますからと猫に言う
猫はわかるんです
極限にバカにされているんだと
だからいやな顔をして無視するんで
あれが可愛くてね
いやな顔して無視することが
可愛いんです
わざわざ言うんです
とにかく仏教の世界では
善人にあげなさいという
話もあるんだけど
誰にあげても徳がありますよ
とも言います、はい
そこで上下関係ちょっと考えましょう
俗世間のモラリティでは
困った人は困っていない、間違った
困ってない人は困っている人にあげる
豊かな人は貧しい人にあげるべき
という上下関係は
仏教では成り立ちません
その場合
困った人にあげましょうという場合は
仏教の言葉は
共有なんです
物に執着するなよと
共有しなさい
これはお布施にならないんです
別な道徳なんで
例えば
数学はハチャメチャできる人は
数学の大物になる
なってその知識を共有する
音楽能力ある人は
桁違いのプロになっちゃって
その能力はみんなと
共有する
英語を喋れる人は
英語喋れない人に教えてあげますよと
まぁ有料でやってしまうと
普通の俗世間の商売になりますけど
有料ではなくて教えてあげますよと
それはすごい善行為になります
それは共有であって
英語を喋れない人に
英語を喋る人が教えたからと言って
英語喋れない人は
卑しい存在ですかね？
だからこの共有するシェアリング
道徳もあります
それはお布施とちょっと違う
モラリティなんです
その場合はたまに上下関係がありますよ
例えば日本で災害に遭って
そこが困っている状態
家も潰れてしまって
別に貧乏な人でも
何でもないんですけどもう
壊れちゃったんですねバランスが
そこで持っている人々は
シェアリングする
家が潰れたんだから
自分のこちらの家で
住んでくださいとかね
シェアリングする
その場合はお布施でもありながら
もっとかっこいいんですよ
あなた困っている？では助けてあげる
という状態ではないんです
これで初めて
社会の不平等状態がなくなります
お釈迦様、仏教で教えているお布施と
シェアリング、共有する
その2つをやり終わってしまうと
世界の不平等はなくなるんです
「施しを行いたいが
困っている人がいなくて困る」
ということはなくなります
なぜならば人間が
現実的平等ではないんです
知識ある人、知識ない人
体力がある人、体力がない人
人気がある人、人気がない人
健康な人、病気の人とか
ですからどうしても
助けてあげることが
成り立つんです
布施と慈悲喜捨の精神が
共鳴しなくてはいけないんですね
私は前、悪口言ったでしょう？
西洋的か現代的な
ドネーションの世界の場合は
困る人が必要です
これって何か
気持ち悪い
だから慈悲喜捨の精神も入れて
お布施の行為をします、次に行きます
時間的にどれくらいだったっけ
今日ページ番号入れるの
忘れてしまったから
どこまで進んでいるのかわからない
はい、次に善人の定義をします
道徳を守らない
悪行為をする人であっても
困っている時は
助けてあげるんです
悪人であってもしょうがないんです
なんか変なことになっている
自分の
意識がなくなっちゃったんです
そこで
悪人であっても
助けることは善行為ですよ
もしかすると
自分がすごい性格の悪い
悪行為ばっかりやってる人ですけど
ある人は自分にすごく親切、優しい
それでその
影響で本人も
じわじわと
悪行為を
制御する可能性はあります
でも必ずそのとおりになるという
保証はないんです
世の中で
しかし悪人でも困っているならば
助ける
なので人に
善の道を教えることは
優れた行為になります
布施の中で最高な布施というのは
人に善の道を教えることなんです
これが
根本的に助かるんだから
ブラックホールの心は
ホワイトホールに
しなくてはいけないんですから
受ける人が善人である場合は
施しが惹き起こす
可能性のある
様々な問題はなくなります
まあだから施しで
問題が起こるでしょう
強引に取り上げるわ
ちょっと責められるわ
あまりにもコマーシャルで
アピールするわ、いろんな事で
トラブルが起こる
金を集めて集めて
それで社会のために何もやっていない
ゴージャスな建物を作ったり
宮殿みたいなものを作ったりとか
そういうこともあり得るんだから
あるいはお布施によって
家族の経済状況が悪化したとか
いろんなトラブルが起こるんですよ
全てトラブルを解決する方法は
善人にあげることです
トラブルは自分で消えます
トラブルは消えます
心は綺麗になります
はい次に行きます
相手を選ぶとき
善人はどうやって判断するのかと
だって知らないでしょうに
悪行為をしない人
こころの汚れが少ない人
素直で、正直に
真面目に生きることに挑戦する人
いるでしょう？
一生懸命頑張って生きている
でもうまくいかないでちょっと
助けてあげる
道徳を守る人
仏教を学び智慧を育てる人
煩悩を無くすために
精進努力をする人
煩悩なくす為に精進努力する
他のことできなくなりますよ
修行中は
はい、買い物行こう
あぁ、ご飯作りましょう
あれやこれやとやってしまうと
瞑想できないでしょう
だからそういう人々を
その修行中助けてあげる
それはものすごい
善行為なんですね
それから最後に煩悩を絶った人
煩悩は全くない
清らかな人
最後に比丘サンガ
比丘サンガと言ってしまうと
覚者も修行者も入りますし
数は決まっていない
だから覚者に
煩悩を絶った人にお布施しちゃうと
こっちは一人の人間なんです
サンガにお布施しちゃうと
覚者も入っているしどれくらい入っるか
わからないんです
だから金額は
あげるものの価値は同じかも
でも徳が
恐ろしく拡大します
まぁそんな感じで善人を
選ぶんです、はい次に行きます
この覚者について
もうちょっと説明します
この覚者っていう悟った人に
煩悩は全くない
内向きの心はもう
無くなっちゃったんです
外向きにしたでしょう？
それで心そのものの働きも
変わっちゃったんです
だから生存するために何かしようという
気持ちすらなくなるんです
それでも
肉体は持っているんだから
肉体を維持するために
自分の心で何かしようとしないんです
ですから
覚者はこの
必要・不可欠なものしか
施しとしていただかないんです
それはほんのわずかなもの
例えば一人の人間が食べる物というのは１日分でしょう
大したことないでしょう
衣食住薬と4つに分けてますけどね
薬っていうのは病気になった時だけ
病気が治るときまで
衣でも
10枚20枚も持ってはいけない
お釈迦様はワンセットでおわりと
覚者にお布施することで
人々にとってはもう
何も感じないぐらい軽いんです
それも必要な時、必要な量だけしか
いただきません
施しを得た覚者は人の心の汚れを
なくすために真理を教えて
実践を指導します
覚者は自分の命を支える事に
関係ないんですけど
仕事はしています
覚者ほど仕事をする人間はいないんです
これは偉大なる仕事をしているんです
それで
弁当一つ差し上げたら
冗談ではないよ、その功徳は
いつでも仏教で使っているのは
asaṅkheyyaṃ appameyyaṃ
無量無制限の功徳になりますよと
ですから
布施主は無量の徳を得ます
布施で期待する働きがあります
何で布施するのかと
自分のこころが清らかになること
貪瞋痴を制御すること
こころの安穏です
このためにお布施をするんです
結果として布施主には
解脱に達する道に進みます
だからそこですね
ずっと説明したのは
内向き、ブラックホール心を
ホワイトホールに入れ替えるために
布施で、布施ってわかりやすくて
貰うよりあげるという事だから
方向が変わるでしょう
そこを理解すればお布施は解脱の道に
人をピシッと押してしまいます
はい
それから最後に
Project・活動に参加する
かかわからないと、とにかく
いろいろprojectsがありますね
学校、病院建設などの
沢山人々の役に立つことに
参加することも
高い徳を得られる布施行為です
わかりやすいでしょう？
これで善人選ぶとかは関係ないんです
このような施設は
使われている限り
布施主の功徳が増えます
どこかで貧しい村に行って
日本ではないんですけど
では、学校を作ってあげる
子供たちに
それで子供たちはずっと
立派な学校をもらったんですから
これを大事に使っているんですね
次の、年々新しい
学生さんたちが入ってきて
建物がある限り
子供たちが勉強している限り
自分の功徳はどんどん増えます
布施行為で執着が消えるならば
最高の結果になります
布施行為で最高の結果っていうのは
解脱に達します
だから布施をすると
所有したあの感情を発見すると
あっ、ここに貪瞋痴があるんだとか
不貪不瞋不痴の状況が
現れてくるんです
そこで在家仏教では
仏道は、1.Dāna 布施　2.Sīla 戒
3.Bhāvanā 瞑想実践
という３セットで成り立っています
これ、在家仏教では
布施は在家に教えているんですから
布施の高度な解説は経典ではないんです
例えば出家している比丘に
あなた布施をしなさいと言っても
何も持ってないんですから
はい、そういうわけで
経典でもあまり見つからない
お釈迦様が仰った
深い意味のところから始めて
Dānaとは、布施とは何かという話が
そこでもって終了します
本当はチャプター3 つぐらい
抜けちゃったんですけど
まぁ今日はしょうがないんです
ありがとうございます
司会の方）はい、ありがとうございます
ちょうど時間になりましたので
これで終了ですね
はい、今日は
会場の利用をお布施した方々と
また黒田さんが私を
運んでくれたんですからね
宅急便ではなかったんですけど一応
車で運んでくれた黒田さんにも
幸福になりますように
解脱に達することができますようにと
誓願いたします
はい、最後の祈願になります
Dukkhappattā ca niddukkhā
Bhayappattā ca nibbhayā
Sokapattā ca nissokā
Hontu sabbepi pāṇino
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
Sādhu! Sādhu! Sādhu!
はい、ありがとうございます